so
our
next
speaker
i met him i wanted to say in 2014
could be yeah that sounds about right
uh back when he was working at the
minnesota vikings and we did a really
cool project together it's been a
pleasure working with him ever since he
does uh we still do a lot of work
together
there's many many nice things i can say
about him he's a very good hockey goalie
which i take very personally
and
the thing is about his name mike band is
a great name
but he was named after the 1965 heisman
trophy winner
mike garrett so please everyone welcome
up mike to the stage
[Music]
ever give a football talk at this
conference i have to play the nfl films
uh orchestra music
i believe that was mandated by you
uh two years ago the first time i spoke
at this conference i'm sorry we're not
together in person but uh i still hope
that we can you know continue to share
the ideas of our awesome community that
uh that continues to grow so today i
would love to talk to you about some of
the projects we're working on uh at
nextgen stats uh one of the special
projects team for the nfl
and today specifically i'm going to talk
about our new fourth down model that
just got released this week and it's
very relevant because tonight is
and as
tonight is
kickoff
so we are talking about uh
we're talking about the cowboys and the
buccaneers tonight on nbc
it's a
really a
awesome
it's it's awesome that we that i could
be here today to talk to you about uh
some of the work we're doing on the
first day of the nfl season so what
we're going to talk about today is the
next gen stats decision guide and what
this is is it's an analytics tool for
fourth down and two point conversions
we're doing this in real time we can do
a post play and we can do it on the
aggregate
really to say what's
how good of a co or how good a coach is
and making decisions on fourth down so
what even am i talking about so let's
say it's fourth down
the decision is
does the team go for it do they kick a
field goal or do they punt so in
football you have four downs and if you
don't if you don't gain a first down
after four downs the other team gets the
ball so in that fourth down that state
is essentially the do or die state for
the drive
in these situations
coaches for years have used
years is a is a relative term in recent
years coaches have uh used a printable
card that essentially has all of the
go for it strategy uh guide that that uh
that alerts them what what situations
that it might be reasonable for the team
to take a risk or miss or
uh really to to align what the numbers
would say in historical situations and
what gives the team the best chance to
win
and since this is a programming
conference i thought why not go start
off with the formula that
powers it all
these individual components are what i'm
going to be breaking down today
and
essentially it's the you can call it the
the the holy grail of pemdas of football
right we're talking about uh
the combination of
of several different models uh that
affect
essentially the decision
so how do we do this well we have let's
the only way to do it is is really to
break down an example and and really to
to understand how the decision is made
so
what i'll be doing during this talk is
using this colts texans example uh from
a game last season
so it's fourth quarter you got three
minutes left in the game the colts have
the ball it's fourth and inches so one
of the advantages next-gen stats have is
this uh the ability to have precise
measurements of how long or the distance
to
the first down marker so a fourth and
one play might actually be fourth in
inches and the probability of converting
is significant is is even higher uh
given the more precise measurement so in
this situation the colts have a 62
chance to win what do you do go for it
kick a field or do you kick a 54-yard
field goal
so i'd like to give a little bit of a
background uh you know i just sort of
wanted to start off with the story we'll
come back to the story in a second so
what i'm going to run through the
evolution of next-gen stats
very quickly go run through the the
models really because this is a a math
driven and programming driven conference
uh so really there are nuances to those
models and then we'll we'll break down
the the decision itself
so
my background is i've uh you know i've
always wanted to work in football and
you know sort of the the inspiration of
moneyball back in the early 2000s
brilliant had the the early
urge to dive into the same idea for
football right so it worked in baseball
how do you do this in football started
off uh when i was an undergrad working
for the football team was able to get a
job with the minnesota vikings in their
scouting department an unbelievable
opportunity while i was there that's how
i was connected to jared land to jared
and that was part of our
my introduction to data science we
created a model in 2015 that led to
picks like stefan diggs in the fifth
round
daniel hunter in the third round aaron
kendricks in the second round all those
were analytically driven pics
so i learned about the the world of data
science i go back to the university of
chicago to get my master's in analytics
and then was able to uh find the perfect
opportunity with the next gen stats team
out here in the los angeles office of
the nfl media
so
really quick what is next gen stats
so in 2014 we uh we were a technology
group started within the nfl uh
group specifically so this we partnered
with zebra technologies and
what we do is we collect player tracking
data with rfid chips so this these are
tags in every player's shoulder pads
tracks their x y location every tenth of
the second if you if you saw my talk
from two years ago i broke down how we
use a lot of tracking derived stats to
do models like completion probability um
and and uh really if you've been if
you're familiar with the big data bowl
uh as i believe our next speaker is
about to talk about
there's a lot of
really cool things happening in the
player tracking space
of really of in football but especially
all sports
so in 2015 all 32 uh stadiums have this
technology granted it's rfid so it needs
uh to have sensors in the device
the club all 32 teams now have access to
all the data the ball has the chip the
field goal markers have the chip the
referees have the chip
clubs receive all of their data so in
2016 they really only received their own
2018 they received all of it and then
the takeoff 2019 to today
next gen stats partners with aws we have
every off season in the past we've
derived some very very cool and that is
a lot of varies and i mean it uh very
cool models uh that answer different
parts of the of of football analytics to
give us new insights across the game
and one of the most
impactful ways analytics is making an
impact today across teams and we're
doing that for the fans is fourth down
in two-point conversion analytics
so how does it work
so it's built on a series of machine
learning models we use amazon sagemaker
to uh to train and to optimize all the
parameters uh we have to build separate
models for for all the different
components of the fourth down and two
point conversion decision
so what what make up the decision so the
first thing we need to do is model for
win probability we need to account for
what is the win problem what is the
likelihood a team wins before the play
what is the
uh win probability if this if the
outcome happens and then come up and
then combine the likelihood of those
occurrences the probability of those
occurrences uh together to essentially
assess what is the value of the decision
so when probability is something we
built last year that that real that
allows us to input hypothetical and also
uh true wind probability swings within
the decision next and this is really a
big project uh undertaken this this
season or this offseason uh with aws's
help we have developed a conversion
probability uh
model that is it's actually boost in
nature and what we have done is say how
likely is a team to convert from fourth
down in this dynamic situation so we
account for how good the offense is how
good the defense is how good the
quarterback is we have the yards to go
we have the actual yards to go from our
player tracking devices so you can see
how all these factors
compounded together affect how the the
are really confounding uh
variables how they affect the decision
and finally we also have to consider the
field goal probability so if the
decision is to go for it that's the
conversion probability if the decision
is to kick a field goal we need to
consider the likelihood of that
occurrence
so again these are the
these are the components that make up
this this main formula that we can
compute each of the value of choices uh
for each of the decisions for whatever
is relevant
so going back to our original uh example
the colts texans were in week 15
uh let's break down how we come up with
our decision so reminder it's fourth and
inches they have a 62 percent chance to
win
and they it it's a tie game so a field
goal can
can take the lead by three but then the
texans would get the ball back and
potentially be able to to win the game
with the touchdown
so what are the questions that make up
the decision and what i'm about to show
is essentially the decision tree that an
nfl coach goes through live in game
we've developed an analytical tool to do
this
in real time and to do it ahead of time
to be able to say what on first down uh
what if what if it were fourth down
so we have our example that the the
colts fourth uh fourth and inches they
can go for it
or they can kick a field goal
so the first question what are the odds
of of
actually being successful if they go for
it so they have an 81 chance of gaining
a first down now what i noted earlier
was that that number was inches fourth
and inches they had a fourth and nine
inches according to our tracking data to
go to convert on fourth down that meant
that a typical fourth and one which
might be an entire yard might be closer
to 75 percent or even 73 percent but
since they only had fourth and nine
inches to go this number was 81 percent
and that's a big deal when you're
talking about these percentages and
weighing the best case
alternatively they can kick a 54-yard
field goal which is roughly about 42
uh according to our field goal
probability model
so now that we have the odds of
converting how does these how do these
decisions affect the game and we can
combine these two to come up with our
decision formula
so
if they convert on first down they have
a 75 percent win probability reminder
they started off going into the decision
with a 62 percent chance of winning so
if they convert that number jumps to 75
percent
if they get stopped that drummer drops
to 45
again
if they kick a field goal if they make
it 71 if it drops 41
you could start to see how the math
would equate to
going for it 69 percent is
is the
expected value of the decision so
it's essentially taking 81 percent times
75
plus
19
times 54 45
that's essentially each component of the
decision formula so going for it you'd
have an expected win probability of 69
kick a field goal 56
the optimal choice the optimal call the
optimal decision the chance that the
decision that gives you the best chance
to win is to go for it by 13
so
how often do coaches make the right call
this is a very cool trend that we're
seeing across the nfl so coaches
are taking analytics into account more
more and more each year at a really high
rate and what we've found is when
coaches kick
let's say when the numbers say
field goal or or punt by two percent or
more
win probability points
coaches have always gotten those
decisions right they're generally in in
favor and and rightly so risk-averse
but on the go for it side that might be
conceived as as more aggressive and
certainly it puts a lot of people's you
know
jobs on the line when they have to
answer those press conferences later of
why they chose that decision
but
as we see in the graph on the left going
for it
when they should is increasing at a
significantly higher rate in each of the
last three seasons
you can check out an article we just
posted uh yes or two days ago
about
really uh breaking down all this article
on nfl.com uh you can also visit our
next gen stats website directly at
nextgenstats.nfl.com
so every you know uh football fans of
certain teams want to know how good is
my coach
at fourth down so these are the most
analytically savvy teams
brown's new rookie head coach last
season who won coach of the year kevin
stefanski
was the most optimal coach in these
situations if you remember the
paul d podesta
is a name from moneyball so he came over
from baseball to football uh into the
browns organization as their chief
strategy officer so they've always been
a more analytically inclined team the
ravens also one of the biggest analytic
departments so you can see how the
coaches break down
the numbers when they should go for it
yeah
so i'm excited for this next part so
before we go follow all of our accounts
on twitter
on
uh
you can follow nextgen stats you can
follow me on twitter but what i'm
excited to share today
is this is the actual first launch
first day launch of the next gen stats
instagram account so the net nfl next
gen i'm going to post the live first
post we have four followers right now so
if everybody can
if you can pull out your instagram
here's the first post it's gonna say
hello ig
and you're gonna see it i hope to see as
many followers as possible tune in
tonight i think for the game um and yeah
i'm uh
with all that i love to summarize it all
with a thank you so much to everybody
thank you jared for having me on and
can't wait to be back next year thanks
everybody
i also love that uh they give mike the
controls to the instagram account uh you
know he's actually for those who don't
know he is the one doing all the
tweeting from the our stats ai accounts
so he is in charge of our social media
for the conference and apparently part
of the nfl social media so you know
don't do anything wrong you know
don't you know post good things about
the giants mainly that's all i really
care about
all right going from one football talk
to another football talk
we have
someone who